[Music]
when Chelsea's 24-year old
whippersnapper goalkeeper capoeira de
Malaga refused to leave the field after
being substituted by his 60 year old
manager I can't say I was surprised
behaving like this now appears to be par
for the course for most caught in a
perfect storm a massive shower of TV
cash falling on some incredibly rich
talented spoilt boys supposedly under
the control of club bosses who'd rather
fire the manager than upset the talent
it's a dreadful example to set for young
people I wouldn't mind if they were
making a fuss about something that
matters like the American football is
protesting about racism but they aren't
why not cap Jung players wages at say 5
grand a week until they're 23 which
should be enough to keep anybody in top
class trainers and ripped jeans if clubs
want to pay more they can pay into a
trust fund that's protected until
they're 24 and if behavior falls short
it goes to the Football Association
wouldn't it be rich if every time one of
the prima donnas throws a tantrum a
chunk of their money gets siphoned off
to support say the grassroots game or
even better women's football
[Music]
well that that discussion when I was
chairman of the AFL that was a
discussion that did go on about whether
and actually came from some of the
agents as well who felt that the kids
were getting too much money too early
could you put into a trust fund for them
the idea of putting in katfoe wages it's
not going to happen
whether you like it no it's not gonna
happen I mean what happened at the
weekend was totally unacceptable and to
find him a week's wages visually what
Chelsea O'Donnell is be pathetic they
probably should have said we're gonna
get rid of him he's going but of course
that's tonight difficult for Chelsea
because they're probably gonna get rid
of the manager as well which they've
which is what they do every - every year
or two years anyway
the problem is the people who are in
charge of the players the manager the
coach relatives have got to have some
in this case everybody saw on those
pictures
he lost the authority Dominion yeah the
problem is Greg I mean you know we're
agreeing violently as a Chelsea
supporter of more than half a century
the problem here is that Chelsea is a
great example but I think it's true
amongst all football clubs that the
authorities seem to have the spines of a
jellyfish actually and they are allowing
the money from not different the players
wages but the merchandising and all the
rest of it to call the shots well this
is I mean remember this is the most
expensive goalkeeper in the world I
think he's the first 72 million yes 72
million pounds they paid for him
therefore if you are in charge of the
club you sit there saying would it be
cheaper to get rid of the manager rather
than get rid of the player and and the
man who was it's obviously in difficulty
anyway I mean I think Joseph's got a lot
more to answer for than the mule problem
Joseph's got is that they've got the
best youth structure in the country
they've won the FA Youth Cup year after
year and none of those kids get through
their system just without making this
sound too much like an episode of on the
ball just briefly I'm Trevor I have
supported Leicester City for more than
50 years and that is another example of
where the players effectively said we
don't want the manager anymore and
they've just made a change I haven't
seen the manager they're getting in is
brilliant but let's just actually say
because I want to explore an issue with
you but we do need to get in what the
goalkeeper that we spoken were kappa
aretha Belaga has said subsequently
which is very good well thank you I have
been practicing although there was
although there was a Peter Shilton would
have been so much easier though there
was a misunderstanding on reflection I
made a big mistake with how I handled
the situation I wanted to take the time
today to apologise fully and in person
to the coach to Willy my teammates and
to the club I have done this and now I
want to offer the same apology to the
fans would be of course being the other
goalkeeper thought he was going to get
on the game I can get dropped last night
drop to the subtle game after that I was
on the bed with the other goalkeepers it
but the way interests me is Trevor this
is private money if Manchester United or
Chelsea or Leicester City want to pay
these blokes as kind of an it's not my
tax is it a painful and if they can make
the economics work and I think in many
cases they can't but that's therefore
that's their worry not my why should you
worry because look at the tax that comes
out lastly before I you we've got a
figure for the amount of tax that comes
out Kurtis to the ey consultancy twenty
sixteen to seventeen Premier League
players paid 1.1 billion pounds in tax
that's a lot of nurses I wouldn't bring
in Carol but the answer to that it's
very simple
I'm not suggesting that government gets
involved here but my worry is the game
that I support that I love is about to
kill the goose that laid the golden egg
because because at some point I mean we
as a club Chelsea we are suffering from
this incredible bad behavior we're not
performing at the level we should do my
point is the more of this goes on at
some point the game itself will become
less attractive and that five billion
quid a year that's coming in will just
disappear you know you can't expect to
pay someone four hundred grand a week
and for them not to be arrogant badly
behaved bearing a man most more 2223
because a lot of the young Muslim player
players pay 10% of their salary to
charity
anyway but but that for me the most
important jamar I remember we destroy a
few years ago when the love of the game
was what was important not the money
involved the game do members story about
Maradona arguably the greatest player in
the world
he left big-league club Barcelona to go
and play for a little league club
Napoli because of his love of the game
this was it this was a club that had
never won a major league with him it did
because what Maradona was interested it
was not money it was making history and
she made history and I don't think young
kids now and players make decisions
about their career based on history and
the love of the game they make it based
purely on money I would say have too
much off there are quite I mean there
are kids at a quite a young age or and
in phenomenal amounts of money who don't
actually play for the teams they're not
in the console yesterday I mean they the
average salary of so 15 to 18 years a
lot of money and there's a lot of stuff
going on that shouldn't be going on
there's a lot of people being bribed
basically to join certain clubs to go to
certain things all the parents abroad
and they all know it that for example is
why I Chelsea of course is faced with a
transfer ban because
whatever it's done with the recruitment
of young paper young young players
clearly hasn't been right but Michelle
your intro quite derogatory and some of
those football players so football as to
your point it's a very private funded
business the Premier League we focused
just on the Premier League it's a
monumental brand now and football goes
way beyond just what goes on in the
stadiums and the terraces like if I
think back to one of my most favorite
memories over the last few years has
been the World Cup and how that World
Cup was pretty much in my memory the
only thing that's managed to bring
together people regardless of any other
opinions brought together society
brought together people so I think
football does a lot more that's the love
of the game that never heard on but I'm
talking about football generally and
when you're talking about this this
Chelsea thing the person at fault there
for me was the manager the manager is
supposed to manage their team if your
team doesn't have enough respect for you
as their leader there's a problem with
you you need to be looking at yourself
your management style and looking at why
on earth a member of your team would
behave in that way and did you see him
in the in the sense it's embarrassing no
I don't think that I don't think that's
right I mean that several players and
Rio Ferdinand made this point on TV last
night in an old Chelsea team sorry it
wouldn't have been an issue because John
Terry Frank Lampard would have got round
him and said I don't care what you think
and got him off the pitch one of the one
of the features there was that the
senior players at Chelsea basically
turned their backs and didn't get
involved so it's not just to do with the
manager but my point I don't think this
is reasonable to say this is just their
own money we regulate this game game at
some point Greg Greg said so let's not
say that you know anything goes that
would be wrong but the FIA isn't in the
face of anything if I isn't that
effective that's the real problem the FA
isn't an effective it's supposed to be I
can't be no well it's not the club why
can't it be because all the money
belongs to the clubs and the FASB FA
realized that this would be this will be
discipline anything for live for the
Premier League itself
it wouldn't be for the FA but because
this is about his their employee and
them being an employer and employee and
this guy I mean the real thing is you
got understanding this kid I'll give you
a bit of sympathy food he's dead
desperately disappointed that it's being
substituted that's what it's about
dumb fee when he was was a journalist in
Ireland that he was a football if I
meant United him for most of his career
at Millwall but a wonderful book about
football in which he said when you get
substituted what you really want just
for the other side to score six and I
think that sums up a lot of life impose
all authority on someone who doesn't
want or take it away from football
you've got a you've got an employee he
won't do as you tell him or will he hear
the Chelsea bore the Chelsea executives
should be back in the manager to say
that player is not playing for me again
and and I think this is exactly right
what lies behind this for me is in a
sense Nick's point we cannot have arenas
particularly popular arenas in which the
grown-ups simply abdicate their
responsibility and say what can we do
about these kids you cannot because this
I mean this has a much wider impact here
keppra is a great player I hope that we
can in some way keep him though I think
that there's a case for saying basically
selling him off now and making it clear
but the fundamental point here is the
game is not the Wild West it has to
operate according to some rules and some
codes and some decencies otherwise we're
going to be in really serious trouble
all right well coming up while I'm being
driven out the vein
[Music]